(upbeat music)
- What time is it?
- We need to get out
of here soon you know.
- I'm telling you, man.
(knock on door)
- Next one better nail it.
- Oh, hey.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, come on through.
- Yo wagwan though, you all right, yeah?
- Good, man.
- Wagwan, my brother.
You alright though yeah?
Top Boy, okay. (laughs)
Okay, I'm not gonna lie,
I'm nervous you know
- Yeah?
- You know, Big Asher D, you know.
(laughs) You know what I mean, like?
♪ Thug of the family, who could I be? ♪
- That's Mack.
- Yeah.
- I know. (mumbles)
- So what you saying?
You got everything prepped?
You good to go?
- I'm not gonna lie to
you, I'm gonna be honest,
I'm from the streets.
I didn't read the brief,
you know what I'm saying?
I just thought I was gonna just
change it up a little bit.
You know what I'm saying?
Everyone's been doing the same thing.
I'm not like everyone else.
So, yeah boom, I'm gonna do some poetry.
- [Michael] You serious?
- [Ashley] Okay
- This is very deep, you know what I mean?
Like, it's about, you know
what I mean, like heartbreak.
Okay, all right. (nervously breathes out)
Okay.
(fingers snapping)
I've gotta click, you know?
Get the shackles out and stuff.
- In your own time.
- Thank you very much.
You bitch!
The end.
- That's it?
- That's it, still.
- So yeah, that was--
- [Michael] It was unique, like--
- It was sick, I know,
I know, that's what I'm saying.
I knew it was sick,
that's why I said boom.
- He didn't say sick,
he said unique.
- Unique!
I'll be like, boom, let me go in there
and do something different.
I mean, who's doing poetry?
But, you know what I mean,
I'm always here for feedback.
- Now what we'll do at this
stage is send you away.
- Okay.
- And maybe in three days time--
- Three days?
Okay, why three days?
What's going on, like?
Have I got it, yes or
no? (laughs nervously)
- Well obviously we've
got other people to see.
- Okay, how can I improve for next time?
- Next time, please,
please, I'm begging you,
wear some shoes.
(comic tuba note)
- Okay, when I looked at the thing,
it didn't say nothing about shoes so--
- [Daniel] Please tell me
you brushed your teeth,
because we didn't put that on there too.
- No no, okay, all right.
- [Ashley] Did you wipe
your batty last night?
(Ashley and Daniel laugh)
- Okay, y'all got jokes.
You're top boys, okay.
The top boys with the jokes.
Does my character need shoes?
Maybe not.
Change up the thing.
- [Ashley] Like I said, two, three days,
we'll let you know.
- Okay, all right then.
- The door is that way.
- Alright thanks for
your time though, yeah.
- Yes, take care.
- Okay, alright.
You changed, cuz!
You changed!
(Daniel laughs disbelievingly)
Nah nah nah, you know what?
Do your thing, Cuz.
- Good luck, good luck, yeah?
I'll be a Star Wars, yeah?
Alright, thank you.
- Bless, bless.
- [Mo] Okay!
That's what should have come in here
and done something different, innit?
I'm getting mad, you know.
I'm getting mad.
I'm a real candidate from the streets!
Cuz, you know what?
I'll just break that.
- [Ashley] You say you really do this?
- I'll start stealing microphones!
How about that?
I'll steal the curtains.
- Can you get security, please?
Thank you.
- I'm gonna call you Asher B.
- [Ashley] Why?
- Buh-bye!
(upbeat music)
(laughs)